Speaker 1: Donald Trump's reaction to the Twitter
files is, as you can imagine, completely and
totally unhinged. TRUMP Not on Twitter, by the
way, the irony of that, but on his own platform,
truth, social, putting together a very long lists,
list of wacky posts and explosions, some of which
we will talk about in more detail. But you have to
get a look at what Donald Trump started saying. So
Trump starting with, wow, that's a really
big story about Twitter and various forms
of government fraud, including specifically
election fraud. The same level of fraud took
place with the other big tech companies, if not
even worse, if that's possible. We are living in
a very corrupt country and as they are saying all
over the Internet, nothing will be done about it
because the Justice Department and FBI are totally
corrupt. But they'll keep investigating boxes
that were legally and openly taken from the White
House. Trump trying to make it seem as though the
real crimes like those exposed by the Twitter
files aren't being investigated. Of course,
no such crimes were exposed. Trump then saying
Trump was right again on 2020 election most
used statement. Trump then saying so with the
revelation of massive and widespread fraud and
deception and working closely with the big tech
companies, the DNC and the Democrat Party. Do you
throw the presidential reelect election results
of 2020 out and declare the rightful winner? Or
do you have a new election? We're going to get
back to that one because that one is so crazy
and insane. Trump continuing again. Trump was
right again on 2020 election most you statement
Biden cheated. Trump won memes retweets retro
notes returned the diamonds. The world is laughing
at the United States of America and it's corrupt
and rigged. Presidential election of 2020. Folks,
it's almost 2023. Unprecedented fraud requires
unprecedented care. I wonder what Mitch McConnell,
the RINOs and all of the weak Republicans who
couldn't get the presidential of 20 presidential
election of 2020 approved and out of the way fast
enough are thinking now they are a disgrace to our
great party. And our nation, which has become
a laughing stock all over the world. Then just
retweeting and posting about, I mean, just
spending endless amounts of time, untruths,
social troth, essential election interference at
a level they've never seen before. Truth social is
so hot. Even the fake and disgusting news media
is in agreement on that, etc. etc. This guy has
only one hammer and that hammer is the hammer of
I really won the election and everything is just
about how I won and how unfairly I am treated.
I'm the ultimate victim. That is ultimately
Trump's message and the most important thing he
wants to get across. For the most part, this is
another one of those unhinged rants and screeds
because he's furious that people aren't praying
at his altar and deferential enough to him. But
there is one piece in there that is particularly
horrifying, completely unconstitutional, which is
demanding, apparently based on the Twitter story,
the Twitter files, which we already said are
really no big story, that he'd be reinstated
as president of the United States. We're going to
deal with that specifically a little bit later in
the show. Make sure that you are subscribed on
YouTube at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman
Show. I do have COVID. My voice is a little
messed up. Bear with me. The show continues.